immaginate una bambina di sei anni molto
timida che crede di essere sposata e
questa bambina viene chiamata la
cattedra per intonare fra martino di
fronte alla sua classe una ventina di
bambini e non ci riesce non esistono
persone stonate questa era la frase che
mi ripeteva sempre la mia prima
insegnante di musica alle elementari
infatti ho capito di non essere stonata
tant'è che ho iniziato a suonare il
violino ho iniziato a suonare il
pianoforte e ho fatto anche il
conservatorio e durante
ovviamente il conservatorio ho studiato
armonia e chi è il padre dell'armonia e
johann sebastian bach e ho suonato
canoni fughe fighette e quant'altro
e la cosa molto interessante del canone
e che è in realtà un opera anche in
matematica estremamente complessa perché
si parte da una melodia si prende questa
melodia se ne fanno copie variazioni si
sovrappone alla prima melodia
cambiandone fondamentalmente tempo e
altezza quindi è una sorta di variazione
in realtà io
memore dei miei studi sia quelli
musicali sia quelli poi di intelligenza
artificiale che appunto sono laureata
bologna in tempi non sospetti con una
tesi su motori di ricerca semantici
quando ho letto la notizia che dei
ricercatori insieme ad un algoritmo a
contro ricercatori sono dei
programmatori e musicisti mi farai reali
che hanno deciso di istruire un
algoritmo facendo sentire a questo
algoritmo tutti i pezzi che sono stati
portati all'eurovision non ho deciso di
lanciare appunto una sorta di tormentone
per l'eurovision creato da un algoritmo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la vita
gesù
il pd
la che vi piaccia o meno il testo
comunque un testo molto poetico perché
come vedete sono parole un po messe a
caso di ferrari ma comunque che può
emulare tranquillamente sospesa chi
comunque può essere un poeta o un
compositore
noi abbiamo visto un esempio di quello
che si chiama artificial naro
intelligenza e scusate per l'inglese
naro tradurre questi termini diventa
sempre un po complicato in questo caso
naro che cosa significa specifico noi al
momento tutto quello che voi vedete sono
algoritmi che sono in grado di dare un
output che può sembrare intelligente o
come in questo caso addirittura creativo
per che operano su domini di conoscenza
molto specifici il solito che sono erano
delle regole molto specifiche ad esempio
i giochi come gli scatti o alfa go o ad
esempio il canone perché il canone è
comunque una composizione matematica
segue delle regole da determinate poi
oltre a questo mettiamoci una quantità
di dati ovviamente enorme che in questo
caso
l'algoritmo in grado di processare in
tempo reale
quindi abbiamo questo output che può
essere considerata una sorta di
intelligenza diciamo così ma al momento
noi sta accadendo anche con
l'intelligenza artificiale quello che
accade un po con la tecnologia e c'è un
paradosso di base molto stesso noi
utilizziamo l'intelligenza artificiale
senza rendercene conto assolutamente
ogni volta che voi utilizzate wave che
vi consiglia un itinerario invece che un
altro perché c'è traffico
ogni volta che utilizzate spotify che vi
consiglia un nuovo gruppo ogni volta che
guardate netflix che comunque vi
consigliamo serie voi state usufruendo
beneficiando di algoritmi speditamente
di marci learning che tra l'altro usano
le vostre preferenze che esprimete anche
guardando quella serie e le riutilizzano
per offrirvi dei contenuti iter
personalizzati non sono contenuti anche
comunicazione e quant'altro quindi
appositamente per voi e che cosa sta
accadendo quello a io cito sempre john
metà
hera è stato chi ha coniato nel 1956 il
termine intelligenza artificiale diceva
non appena funzionerà non la chiami non
la chiameremo più intelligenza
artificiale che cosa succede
è la tecnologia invisibile noi la
utilizziamo ma non ci rendiamo conto di
utilizzarla l'esempio classico e voi
utilizzate la lavatrice semplicemente
perché vi mette wright un beneficio non
ne avete paura immagino spero della
lavatrice che accada insieme a voi ma
con intelligenza artificiale invece ne
abbiamo paura perché non è considerata
ancora come la lavatrice ma
fondamentalmente la nostra immaginazione
è stata formata da tantissimi film di
fantascienza e immaginate che anche io
sono appassionata di fantascienza in cui
non si sa perché questa intelligenza
artificiale prima o poi diventa cattiva
diventa cattiva ci vuole dominare fare
cose brutte e quant'altro anche io mi
chiedo se fosse così intelligente forse
non si preoccuperebbe di noi può avere
un anni non avrebbe altre occupazioni e
fondamentalmente noi di cosa soffriamo
soffriamo della paura di una minaccia
invisibile è una sindrome clinicamente
studiata e spesso purtroppo si manifesta
nei stato delle nuove tecnologie perché
fondamentalmente non le capiamo al
momento ci sono propri esperti che sono
in grado di scrivere gli algoritmi e
quindi alla nostra reazione istintiva e
quella di averne paura e immaginare
appunto chissà quali piani malefici che
a questo algoritmo il termine stesso non
aiuta tant'è che artificiale che cosa
significa che fondamentalmente è falso
non ed è genuino e ci vuole ingannare
come vediamo qua è anche il termine
intelligenza è fondamentalmente un
termine estremamente vago se noi
pensiamo alla definizione di
intelligenza non ha definizione in
continua evoluzione 40 anni fa era
considerato un intelligente una persona
con delle forti capacità di carattere
logico matematico un ragionamento
astratto ad oggi abbiamo riconosciuto
ben nodi tipi di intelligenza tra cui
c'è l'intelligenza naturalistica
l'intelligenza cinestetica
l'intelligenza interpersonale solo per
citarne
quindi è un concetto di evoluzione cosa
significa noi non sappiamo esattamente
cos'è l'intelligenza cerchiamo di
misurarla
cerchiamo di misurare queste
manifestazioni ma non c'è un concetto
definito quindi veniamo al tema che
abbiamo introdotto ad oggi siamo in
quella che chiamiamo neo intelligence ci
sono moltissimi dibattiti una macchina
potrà mai diventare intelligente come
l'essere umano
allora sicuramente al momento non ci
siamo
quello che ma c'è anche da capire cosa
significa essere come un essere umano o
intelligenti con un essere umano
ci sono alcune caratteristiche un
abbiamo visto quella che la creatività è
da capire cosa si intende per creatività
la creatività è reale delle variazioni
di un qualcosa per già stato dato come
nel caso del dell'algoritmo che abbiamo
visto prima o e altro esiste la menzogna
noi esseri umani siamo capaci di mentire
una macchina al momento non è capace di
mentire
noi esseri umani siamo capaci di provare
emozioni è assolutamente una macchina
non può provare emozioni ma soprattutto
siamo auto coscienti abbiamo
consapevolezza di noi stessi
cosa che una macchina è molto lontano da
fare
diciamo i filosofi perché in questo caso
si parla di filosofia o di cercare di
prevedere un futuro molto lontano poi
che cosa assurdo dal momento in cui
creeremo una general intelligence a quel
punto potremo creare una super
intelligence perché la macchina delle
caratteristiche di alcuni casi superiore
a una memoria maggiore può processare
dati puoi fare calcoli più velocemente
quindi in un certo senso se creiamo una
general diventerà super molto spesso
questo si chiama anche singolarità nel
momento in cui si svilupperà una
singolarità allora dovremmo capire come
reagire qui da cui nascono da verso
l'apocalittica ecco la mia opinione che
siamo molto molto molto lontani se voi
avete mai provate ad educare un chatbot
vi renderete conto di quanto siamo
lontani anche ad avere una buona
intelligence e appunto lasciamo il mito
e veniamo un po alla realtà io vorrei un
po spiegare come viene utilizzata ad
oggi 20 licenza artificiale nelle
aziende perché si tratta anche un po del
mio lavoro in questo caso in moltissimi
casi si tratta di automazione di
processo ripetitivi quindi io oggi uso
il termine ea il termine molto anche uno
spesso si tratta di robotica forse santo
mansion
che cosa significa automazione per
attività uno solo ripetitive interessate
data entry riconciliazione validazione
dei dati quindi le cose che vengono
affidate a delle ad erchie in questo
momento poi un altro applicazione molto
interessante sono quelli di algoritmi
che grazie alla loro capacità di calcolo
e quindi processare molti dati in tempo
reale possono identificare degli schemi
schemi che di solito per un umano sono
invisibili perché sono invisibili perché
la macchina è in grado di correlare di
provare delle correlazioni magari tra
dei dati che apparentemente per noi non
sono correlati è un'evoluzione di
un'analisi statistica però visto che ci
sono molti più dati o paralizzare il più
bello su monte più efficiente di noi
umani e che cosa succede poi visto che
si possono analizzare molti dati storici
e non solo i dati storici
anche in questo caso capire quando è
accaduto cosa e perché si parla di
analisi non solo predittiva quindi
capire quando potrà succedere un certo
tipo di mal funzionamento del
macchinario ma anche prescrittiva nel
senso il l'algoritmo ti dice anche che
cosa dovrei dovresti fare per prevenire
quell'avvenimento oppure quando avviene
che cosa devi fare per correggerlo e
quindi si parla di next up su che cosa
significa di suggerirti delle azioni che
dovreste fare un certo tavo e gli esempi
appunto reali uno dei problemi della
fifa sono quello del mercato delle
scommesse non solo scommesse clandestine
ma proprio di incontri truccati spesso
gli incontri che non esistono
e questo perché viene fatto per
riciclare del denaro sporco e hanno
calcolato che
un giro di affari di 140 miliardi di
dollari all'anno quindi molto importante
incontri e non c'era modo fino ad oggi
di capire quali di questi incontri
fossero veri o meno
quindi che cosa hanno creato un
algoritmo che analizza quelli che sono
considerati segnali deboli cosa
significa questo incontro noi ci sono
biglietti che sono stati due minuti non
ci sono dei commenti sui social media
non c'è una trasmissione televisiva non
c'è una trasmissione radiofonica tutti i
segnali che sono dei segnali di allarme
a questo punto viene segnalato e umano
verifica dice sì non era un incontro
vero caso molto simile in questo caso
sia per scoprire delle frodi ma anche
per ottimizzare il trattamento con
national health system britannico che
appunto ha calcolato che risparmierà
qualcosa come 156 milioni di dollari con
questa algoritmo che non solo
identificherà quelli che sono chiamiamo
le frodi cioè nel senso quando si è
richiesto un esame ma non si aveva
bisogno dell'esame ma soprattutto si è
richiesto un esame sbagliato per quel
tipo di malattia e quindi ottimizzare e
fare in modo che venga effettuato levano
corretto o lo degli usi ad esempio che
vediamo che sta nascendo e quello che
non è solo sul settore specifico ma è un
po ovunque dal marketing all'e commerce
a decidere quale fornitore pagare prima
appunto è quello di supporto alle
decisioni cosa significa il sistema
analizza una grande quantità di dati ha
comunque un obiettivo gli viene data una
funzione e poi decidere guarda puoi
offrire che suggerisce di offrire un
certo tipo di sconto ad esempio ad un
fornitore perché è sempre stato un tempo
facendo annunciati tipo di azioni oppure
a una storia creditizia migliore oppure
ti può suggerire anche ad esempio che
tipo di canale utilizzare per
raggiungere a livello di marketing un
consumatore non solo il tipo di canale
ti suggerisce poor's notification invece
di mail ma anche il tempo ti dice guarda
manda una cultura di fiction
4 2 4 di sera e non alle 8 di mattina
perché ho verificato che questa persona
non le legge quindi poi non è talmente
una serie di suggerimenti per le azioni
da fare ma adesso stiamo passando ad
un'altra fase
che cosa significa l'intelligenza
artificiale iniziato a vedere sentire
pensate ai sensori oppure alla computer
vision o comunque a tutti i device che
sono in grado di ascoltare di rispondere
e questo ci fa passare ad una nuova fase
che è chiamata per sezione ai per
sfidarla vi faccio vedere un bivio
[Musica]
ok questi rischi
appunto questo è un progetto che è stato
fatto dalla città di albuquerque che
fondamentalmente in questo caso qual è
la cosa molto bella è che c'è allora un
cittadino parla con un agente
conversazionale ma questo viene
automatico tradotto in un testo che
viene ricevuto dalla persona che si
occupa di mandare in questo caso delle
delle persone a cancellare un graffito
tutto in modo automatico la persona
schiaccia un bottone e la squadra di
operatori che devono pensare di un sito
di anatomicamente mandata e lo stanno
facendo per alcune attività come il
grafico è un esempio ma anche per il
recupero di animali da compagnia
smarriti oppure per ritirare la
spazzatura e c'è tra quindi città molto
avanzata
altro esempio di tito di sensori è il
world beat project ad esempio tutti
sappiamo che le api da miele sono non in
estinzione ma se siamo a vederne una
diminuzione preoccupante di colonie di
api da miele che sono comunque
responsabili dell'impollinazione di
sette delle dieci tipi di piante che
forniscono il 90 per cento del
nutrimento a tutti quanti umani e
animali ma è un problema molto rilevante
e fondamentalmente che cosa sia iniziato
a fare se iniziato a inserire dei
sensori nelle arnie sono chiamate armi e
connesse questi sensori non solo
verificano quello che è la variazione di
temperatura dell'unità di produzione del
miele
addirittura sono molto avanzati per cui
possono in un certo senso monitorare il
battito delle ali e il movimento delle
zampe delle api e da questo si può
capire che stanno cercando di cambiare
posto perché c'è qualcosa che non va e
quindi si possono rinnovativa re delle
azioni preventive come eliminare un
possibile predatore o comunque cercare
di ritardare che lo sciame si sposti
quindi noi che cosa abbiamo visto
andiamo di sé alcune fasi del 20 vigenza
artificiale abbiamo visto a quella
internet quella percettiva e adesso noi
siamo di fronte ad un nuovo momento che
è quello di avere
intelligenza artificiale completamente
automatica noi siamo a questa in questo
schema siamo tra il momento diciamo 3 in
alcuni casi a quello 4 cioè nel senso
che noi non abbiamo delle ancora dei
sistemi completamente automatici e dove
stiamo andando cioè l'obiettivo sarà
quando si parla anche di macchinari
completamente automatici è in questo
caso che hanno la piena responsabilità
di tutte le loro azioni
molto spesso non si tratta di un
problema tecnologico e parzialmente un
problema tecnologico in realtà siamo noi
umani che non siamo pronti noi pensiamo
a tutto il dibattito etico su quando
parliamo di punto di stage riding cara
di automobili che si guidano da soli in
realtà noi non abbiamo un framework di
carattere etico nel senso chi è
responsabile il guidatore il produttore
del software
chi ha prodotto l'auto eccetera e spesso
non abbiamo neanche questo framework
infrastrutturale spesso come anche da
oggi parliamo di che cosa succederà in
futuro quale sarà il problema del lavoro
e di nuovo per questo che sembra bologna
per citare è così paradiso tutti
apocalittici o integrati no abbiamo tra
quelli che gridano al miracolo nel senso
che l'intelligenza artificiale sarà la
panacea di tutto e quindi non l'aver
vorremmo più e saremmo in questo mondo
dorato in cui lavoreremo 4 5 ore al
giorno e ci sono gli altri che dicono eh
vabbè ma se non lavoriamo non
guadagniamo quindi ci sarà una crescita
della disoccupazione eccetera
ecco probabilmente come in tutti i casi
non stiamo guardando il reale problema
l'intelligenza artificiale o tutti i
sistemi di informazione sono già
applicati dalle aziende continueranno a
venire essere applicati perché
garantiscono una maggiore efficienza
garantiscono anche dei rischi nei
risparmi e quant'altro quindi il punto
non è fermare questo è questo il punto è
capire cosa sarà necessario fare in
futuro
in realtà questo c'è un tetto di raiden
stack che ha iniziato la fonda lisi
dalla germania
e lui ha fatto delle proiezioni per
capire che cosa succederà nel mondo del
lavoro
la realtà e non è chi non ci saranno
posti di lavoro l'economia crescerà
grazie anche la tecnologia ma non saremo
pronti a come dire effettuare quei tipi
di attività qui ci saranno richieste
quando noi parliamo di labor show the
hills che cosa significa c'è la
richiesta di non so persone che sappiano
istruire un algoritmo persone che
sappiano decidere quando il caso di
affidare un certo tipo di attività a un
algoritmo a un umano ci sarà mancanza di
queste persone non di lavoro quindi il
problema è un problema di educazione ma
anche di capire qual è il problema reale
è un problema di abbracciare la
molteplicità la molteplicità degli skill
noi umani siamo bravi a fare delle cose
le macchine sono più bravi di noi a fare
altro
quindi vorrei concludere con
un'esortazione che non è solo quello a
[Musica]
educare e a capire meglio che qualche di
cosa si parla quando si parla di
intelligenza artificiale ma soprattutto
di imparare a ballare e una giga che una
gb a un canone anche con le macchine e
anche con le macchine intelligenti
grazie mille